what up space fam golden here from anime
upper back at it again with another
naruto video this time we are continuing
the explaining every clan series with
the hyuga clan definitely one of my
favorites if you do enjoy seeing these
naruto videos and want to keep them
coming the best you could do is change
the hokage within and smash that like
button until it changes colors if you
haven't make this the video subscribe
and this is crucial hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
naruto videos and while you wait for the
next video to come out feel free to
check out my huge and growing naruto
playlist that includes videos on all the
kage uzumaki clan members otsutsuki clan
members and much more link to that is in
the description as always leave
suggestions for video topics or clans
you would like to see covered next now
without further ado let's jump into its
spoilers and all the hyuga clan is one
of the four noble clans of the village
along with ochiha akimichi and aburame
they've been called the strongest clan
in the village and are associated with
the byakugan aka the all-seeing white
eye their kekagenkai and the gentle fist
fighting style both of which we'll get
into in more detail later on in the
video the hyuga clan are descendants
from hamura osutsuki the fraternal twin
brother of hagoromo otutsuki as we know
the clan is separated into the main
house and the branch house and while the
main house runs the family the branch
house is supposed to protect the main
house the branch members would also be
branded with a curse mark and become
so-called caged birds using this curse
mark the main house can easily hurt the
mind of a marked branch member or even
kill them the curse only disappears
after that after the secret of the
byakugan has been sealed away the
byakugan is perceived as being so
valuable that the head ninja of
kumogakurei was sent to konoha under the
cover of a peace treaty in order to
secretly kidnap a huge clan member and
obtain their biakugan this led to one of
the weirdest moments in naruto hiyashi
hyuga kinata's dad stopped the
kidnapping by killing the kumo ninja in
turn kumo gakurei demanded the corpse of
hiyashi for breaking the peace treaty i
find this super weird because if someone
is on your property and kidnapping your
kid what can you expect but nevertheless
konoha wanted to avoid war so hiyashi's
twin hizashi the father of neji
sacrificed his life for konoha and for
the hyuga clan and this plan actually
worked because his biakugan was sealed
away as he died kumo gakurei didn't get
their hands on the byakugan now that we
have the basic info about the clan out
of the way let's turn to the clan
members for number one let's start
things off with neji huga a member of
the branch family and a prodigy even
compared to the standards of the skilled
huga clan when i was first experiencing
naruto manga during elementary school
neji and the byakugan were the coolest
at least until neji hurt our precious
hinata and that was definitely not cool
the english weekly shonen jump magazine
was covering the tuning exams at the
time and as far as i was concerned the
byakugan was even better than the shot
and gone just like neji was better than
sasuke so being able to cover nedji in a
video like 15 years later is pretty
crazy and very cool but anyways let's
turn to neji's abilities while watching
neji fight hinata the third hokage
thought that and i quote those who've
called neji the greatest genius in hyuga
history haven't overstated the case end
quote the significance of such a
statement cannot be overemphasized since
a is coming from the third hokage who
knows what he's talking about and b the
hugo clan is already one of if not the
strongest clans in the village and c
konoha's history is full of strong
ninjas so the fact that nedji is the
greatest genius in hugo history is just
insane because he's a member of the
branch family he was technically
forbidden from learning the clan's
advanced techniques but the dude is such
a genius he learned how to perform them
by simply observing others perform them
during the tuning exams rockley referred
to nedji as the strongest junior ninja
and said that the hyuga fighting style
was the strongest school of taijutsu in
konoha but he wasn't just great at hyuga
stuff he also finished at the top of his
class in the academy further cementing
his status as an all-around genius even
after he lost to naruto he continued to
excel and ended up being the first of
his generation to be promoted to joni in
terms of nature transformations neji has
access to earth fire and water release
obviously nedji has the byakugan like a
lot of other hyuga will see on this list
and the byakugan has a bunch of cool
powers including near 360 degree vision
there is one small blind spot and edgy
even figured out a way to overcome this
to an extent by emitting chakra around
the blind spot doing so allowed him to
sense the attack earlier and to slow the
attack which gave him much much more
time to respond the byakugan also allows
neji to see the chakra pathway system
and the 361 pressure points aka nodes of
chakra not even the shotgun can see
furthermore neji can accurately hit them
in battle in order to halt the flow of
an enemy's chakra or to enhance it
controlling it any way he wishes to the
biaku gun also allows neji to see
through objects kind of like x-ray
vision and it's been shown in part 2
that he can see things from at least 800
meters away even in a heavily wooded
area let's narrow in on edgy's gentle
fist fighting style as well for a moment
the huge clan signature fighting style
it is through this fighting style that
neji can cut off the flow of chakra
through an opponent's body by hitting
their chakra nodes what i really like
about this fighting style is that it is
gentle it seems so subtle and fluid and
yet can do so much damage as we saw
during neji's fight with hinata then
there's the eight trigrams 64 palms this
secret thai jutsu that only the head of
the clan and their heirs are supposed to
know and yet nedji ended up figuring it
out through observation the user
envisions themselves inside the a
trigram symbol and can deliver many
quick and accurate attacks to people or
block incoming projectiles located
within the a trigram symbol the a
trigram 64 palms as the name suggests
allows the user to strike 64 of the
opponent's chakra nodes blocking off the
flow of chakra and making it difficult
for the target to even move fun fact
each set of strikes take the same amount
of time even though almost each
subsequent one includes double the
strikes compared to the former so the
user has to be increasingly fast with
each subsequent set and the last 32 are
especially difficult to pull off in the
anime nenji takes this jutsu even
further with 8 trigrams 128 palms where
the 7th set now consists of a whopping
64 consecutive strikes then there is a
trigram's palms revolving heaven aka
palm rotation which allows naji to emit
a large amount of chakra from points all
over his body he can use it the instant
before an attack reaches him and it
halts the attack with a cocoon of chakra
then he moves his body in a circle like
a beyblade repelling and reflecting the
attack if for whatever reason naji can't
rotate he can still expel chakra from
every tenketsu or chakra note on his
body and he did so in order to escape
kisame's water prison technique in shibu
then we also saw eight trigrams vacuum
palm aka trigrams air pom it's similar
to the previous techniques except in
this case the force being released is
being concentrated in a particular
direction with a palm thrust neji uses
what looks like a powerful air current
to attack the opponent's vitals from a
distance and this move can even send
someone as strong as kisame flying back
when used in conjunction with other
hyugas like hinata for instance the
force of this attack is increased
accordingly rather than just being used
as an offensive attack this move can
also be used defensively to stop
incoming attacks or projectiles i won't
give all of neji's stats but i will give
the latest one according to the data
book it is understandably his highest
score and he got a 4 out of 5 in
ninjutsu a 4.5 in taijutsu a 2 in genji
to a three in intelligence a 2.5 in
strength a 4.5 in speed a 3.5 in stamina
and a three in hand seals giving him a
total score of 27 notably in the same
data book our main character naruto only
got 26 so it's definitely not a bad
score but that pretty much covers neji
for the purposes of this video as we
know he goes on to protect hinata and
naruto with his life cementing him as a
fan favorite character and now we move
on to the subsequent characters who
shouldn't take as long to explain since
i had to explain the specifics of the
biakugan and hyuga clan techniques but
now that i have we can move through the
remaining hyuga more quickly for number
2 let's look at neji's father hisashi
hyuga ajonine in konoham he was born
seconds after his twin brother and
future hinata father hiyashi and thus
hizashi ended up being a member of the
branch house rather than the heir to the
main house like his son hizashi was
given a curse seal so that the main
family could treat him like a slave he
eventually kind of like nedri sacrificed
his life for the main branch in this
case for his brother hiyashi after
hiyashi killed the kumugakura kidnapper
again i hate that the village thought it
was necessary to give anyone over for
the death of a kidnapper but hey naruto
characters need their tragic backstories
according to nedji his father had
practically equivalent strength to his
brother hiyashi and in a flashback
during chapter 105 he quickly brought
hiashi down with one blow it wasn't a
real fight and he simply wanted hiyashi
to let him decide his own fate but still
notable as the older twin remained on
the ground for a while afterward and
kabuto clearly thought he was strong
because he was one of the fighters he
reanimated in preparation for the fourth
shinobi war he could obviously use the
byakugan the gentle fist style and he's
even shown using a trigram's palm
rotation to repel attacks according to
the first data book he got a three out
of five in ninjutsu a foreign taijutsu a
two in genjutsu a three in intelligence
a four in strength up four in speed of
4.5 and stamina and a five enhanced
seals making his total score 29.5
notably hiyashi got a 29.5 in the first
data book as well further solidifying
the fact that they were very close in
terms of strength for number three let's
look at the other twin hiyashi hyuga the
father of hinata and hanabi and the
grandfather of boruto and himawari his
story was covered in naji section and
again hizashi's section so let's jump to
his abilities here in boruto he was said
to have more knowledge and understanding
of the huga clan and their abilities
than anyone else which is not weird for
a leader of the hugo clan but still
worth noting as one of konoha's top
ninja hiyashi played his part during
orochimaru and tsunagakure's attempt to
destroy konoha during the fourth shinobi
war he was present to help battle the
tent tales and even saw with his
byakugan how the ten tales managed to
destroy a far-off village as usual he
has the byakugan abilities and mastery
over the gentle fifth style as mentioned
he killed the head ninja of kumo gakurei
who was trying to kidnap hinata he
killed this extremely high ranking
shinobi with one blow without even
getting hurt in the process that's a
giant flex if i ever saw one he's been
shown using the moves we've covered like
palm rotation air pump and notably he
uses air wall palm with both hands to
push back one of the ten tails tails by
himself as mentioned in the first data
book hiashi tied with his twin with a
29.5 but in the second data book where
he was included but his late brother
wasn't he scored 30 having improved his
taijutsu which went from a 4.5 to a
perfect five i love to see even older
characters improving over the course of
the series like this now on to hugo
number four the father of hiyashi and
hizashi we don't have his specific name
but he's referred to as hyuga elder and
he was the former head of the hyuga clan
when kumo wanted hiyashi's body it was
this elder who said that is why we have
the cadet branch our only hope is to
hand over hizashi's corpse as your body
double and quote when hiyashi was
hesitant his father told him that and i
quote for the sake of the family you
must possess a heart of iron even toward
your own brother end quote not much is
known about his specific abilities
except that he has the biakugan and the
abilities associated with it of course
because he was the head of the family at
one point we can assume that he's
especially strong even among the hyuga
and that he has great mastery over the
gentle fist fighting style for hugo
number five let's cover hanabi hyuga the
daughter of hiyashi hyuga and the
younger sister of hinata hyuga during
chapter 78 we actually get a flashback
where hinata is referred to as
superfluous to the clan because she
cannot even measure up to hanabi who is
five years younger than her so clearly
hanabi was born very talented from the
get-go before it was officially brought
up many felt that she should be the
heiress of the clan rather than hinata
because of just how talented she was
even from a young age in the anime
hanabi even straight up beats hinata in
a fight but part of the reason was also
that hinata was hesitant to harm her
little sister hiyashi helped her through
intense training to master the gentle
fist style in boruto she was seen
performing the advanced techniques of
the clan like a trigrams palm rotation
and a trigrams air pawn in the anime
hiyashi noted that hanabi's biakugan is
very powerful almost as powerful as
genius negi's in the last naruto movie
hanabi also states that her biakugan's
perception abilities are as good as any
grown hyugas it is also telling that in
the movie toneri otsutsuki called
herbiakugan especially pure and
specifically targeted them for his own
use hinata ends up being stronger than
hanabi as we'll get into when we cover
hinata but there is no doubt that hanabi
is among the most talented hyuga and for
a while many thought she would far
surpass hinata in power hyuga number six
is hinata and hanabi's mom who only
appears in the anime she of course is
the wife of hiyashi hyuga the leader of
the clan her defining attribute was
kindness rather than strength as hinata
wished in the anime to be strong like
her father and kind like her mother we
don't see her fight but we can assume
she can use all of the usual byakugan
abilities hyuga number 7 is hinata hyuga
the hyuga princess herself and best girl
in the series as we saw hinata used to
be regarded as a failure by her clan in
her fight against neji during the tuning
exams neji told her that a weak
personality like hers won't become
strong a failure is always a failure and
all that negative stuff he not the loss
but fought bravely showing she wasn't a
weak person who would give up or run
from a fight in one of naruto's most
touching moments she was even ready to
die at payne's hands for naruto's sake
she definitely proved kidnaji wrong as
the older version of him would readily
admit with her byakugan hinata can do
the usual biakugan stuff and for hinata
i'll get a bit more specific again we
talked about being able to see a
person's pathway system and the 361
tanketsu with gentle fist style like
naji hinata can hit those nodes and
inject her own chakra into her opponent
in order to halt the flow of that
person's chakra or enhance it
controlling it any way she wishes in
this way hinata can cause severe damage
to any internal organs located near the
attack chakra points even though she
started off as a screw-up by adulthood
she was highly regarded for her mastery
of the gentle fist fighting style
ninjutsu is not hinata's main focus but
she can use fire and lightning release
and now things get really interesting
just like naruto and sasuke got some
chakra from hagoromo otsutsuki hinata
got some chakra from the sage of
sixpat's younger brother hamura
otsutsuki the ancestor of the hyuga clan
as a result she got a significant power
up and her chakra changed from blue to
purple hamura even recognized hinata as
the biakugan princess which is
definitely a perfect name for the best
girl with this chakra upgrade she can
replenish naruto's insane chakra
reserves in moments and she doesn't even
look drained afterwards she can also see
20 kilometers in any direction with her
byakugan in contrast we've only seen
neji as i mentioned use his byakugan to
see as far as 800 meters so hinata can
potentially see 25 times further than
the talented negi which is just insane
to think about at the end of the day
hinata went from being a failure in the
eyes of her clan to becoming the
strongest hyuga significantly surpassing
even nedji she's more of a mom than a
fighter these days in boruto but don't
let that fool you she is the perfect
wife for naruto the strongest shinobi in
history not only are they both strong
they both proved kid neji wrong by
showing that even screw-ups can become
the best hyuga number eight is actually
himawari uzumaki the daughter of naruto
and hinata and the little sister of
boruto although borton himawari do carry
those umaki clan name they are
considered to be members of both those
maki and hyuga clans himawari is two
years younger than boruto making her 10
years old during the boruto movie
himawari has clearly got a lot of
potential since she awakened the
byakumat at a very young age when she
did so she scared boruto who claimed
that she was super strong all of a
sudden it's a moment of comedic relief
but she ends up punching naruto in the
gut so hard that even kurama feels it at
10 years old she learns to activate the
biakugan at will like other byakugan
users when it's activated himawari has
an almost 360 degree field of vision she
can see across great distances and even
through solid surfaces and she can
perceive people's chakra pathways and
potentially close off their chakra
points in addition to the byakugan
himawari can hit a bullseye with ease
proving that she's already skilled at
shuriken jutsu and her natural chakra
control unlike kidnartos is impressive
enough that she can already temporarily
stick to vertical surfaces by focusing
chakra into her feet while her peers
fell immediately when they tried she
clearly has immense potential that's not
surprising looking at her parents we
just gotta hope she becomes a ninja
rather than a flower shop owner or
something else non-ninja related i'd
absolutely love to see her kicking butt
alongside boruto in the future hugo
number nine is the one and only borto
uzumaki borto is a prodigy and clearly
has good genes his father is the
strongest shinobi and the descendant of
the famous uzumaki clan and son of the
fourth hokage while his mother is a
member of the famous hugo clan and we
talked about how they both possess
otsutsuki chakra in the anime during the
getting exams kakashi suggested that
boruto was not only exceptional compared
to his class members he was also at a
chunin level according to kakashi borto
excels in all areas like his father
borto has large chakra reserves and good
chakra control being able to perform
one-handed seals he's said to have the
potential for senjutsu meaning he could
enter sage mode down the line like
naruto he likes using shadow clones that
haseng god with his own vanishing spin
on it and can even perform the much
feared sexy jutsu rather than wanting to
be like his hokage father borto chose
sasuke as his mentor and so it makes
sense that he can summon the giant snake
garaga rather than a toad with some help
from sasuke borto became quite skilled
in shuriken jutsu which if you still
don't know by now it's the art of
throwing kunai shuriken and other
projectiles he can even coat his
shuriken in lightning puerto's natural
affinity is you guessed it lightning
release but he can also use wind release
naruto's natural affinity and water
release as well then there is boruto's
own op twist his karma his karma is a
backup of momoshiki osutsuki and it
allows borto to access the otsutsuki's
powers ottotsuki are godlike in the
naruto world they are the strongest
clans so this potentially gives boruto
the possibility of surpassing naruto
especially after naruto lost kurama
recently in the manga when activated the
karma mark gives him a significant boost
across the board and lets him absorb
ninjutsu with another karma user he can
even create a dimensional portal when
pushed the will of momoshiki can take
control of boruto kind of like how the
nine tails would take control of naruto
in the past in chapter 43 of the manga
this form lets borso fly unleash massive
the sengons and more it allows him to
straight up flex on the powerful borrow
and he is even to thank for sasuke
losing his renagon more recently then
there's boruto specialized the drogon
meaning pure i in japanese its power is
associated with the strongest of clans
dyototsuki it will probably continue to
evolve and perform new abilities but for
now it can see the flow of chakra track
people based on their chakra allow one
to see a person's chakra pathway system
and like the biakugan identify its key
points and predict where the original
space time ninjutsu used by the otsuki
will be used through naruto and hinata
berton away has connections to hagaromo
osutsuki chakra and hamura osutsuki
chakra and of course he has potential
access to momoshiki otozuki chakra since
as i mentioned the otozuki are godlike
characters in naruto there is no doubt
with all this ototuki influence that
he'll end up being one of the strongest
fighters of all time hugo number 10 is
tokuma hyuga in naruto shibu then muta
aburame said that tokuma has the
sharpest byakugan of all the hyuga in
the data book it stated that he's an
adept tracker and that he's trained his
byakugan for that specific purpose i
like how you can take the same power
like the byakugan and train it in
specific ways like this obviously he can
also use the usual byakugan powers like
seeing nearly 360 degrees x-ray vision
and so on tokuma proves to be a brave
and selfless man when he offered to hold
the resurrected akatsuki back so the
team could escape however he obviously
wasn't strong enough for the akatsuki
and sasuri used him as a puppet to fight
his allies until he was finally freed by
omoi of kumogakure hugo number 11 is ko
hyuga he is from the main house and he
serves as a bodyguard for hinata he
tells us during chapter 430 that if
something were to happen to hinata in
hiyashi and lady hanabi's absence he
would never be forgiven and then he
tells hinata not to concern herself with
him in the anime for years he served as
hinata's caretaker although we don't get
to see him in action frequently he must
be one of the stronger hyuga if he was
given such an important job like
protecting the hyuga heiress hugo number
12 is iroha hyuga a jonine of the clan
in the data book we're told that he's a
serious type who's not good at dealing
with abnormal situations he was assigned
to kumo barrier team who were in charge
of preventing killer b and naruto from
leaving their barrier of course the
barrier didn't succeed in stopping them
but iroha was the one to first spot and
warn about an incoming naruto and killer
b attack thanks to his powerful byakugan
eyes and now we move on to hyuga number
13 jorgeto hyuga another jonine not
surprisingly for a hyuga during the
fourth shinobi war we see him being put
on sensory in watch duty hohito proves
to be useful when they run into an
injured muta aburame he notices that
it's not aburame beetles in his bag but
a large white mass of chakra this info
helps them figure out that it's
deidada's detonating clay that's pretty
much his strength and he later notices
and warns that daedara turned shin into
a bomb and this allows him to avoid the
deadly attack even if akuga is not as
skilled in combat as neji let's say they
can clearly be very useful in military
operations and their biakugan abilities
can mean the difference between life and
death for their teammates number 14 is
an anime only called natsu hyuga a
female ninja from the clan she possesses
the biakugan and serves as a maid within
the hugo clan more specifically she is
hanabi's caretaker it would make sense
if natsu is considerably skilled since
she is charged with caring for hanabi a
very important member of the main branch
but we don't really see her powers in
action i gotta say though i wish i also
had a cute maid that could kick butt
like natsu hyuga and as bonus i'll
mention mukai kokinata who is not
classified as a hyuga clan member but is
a jonine who has hyuga clan ancestors as
a result he is able to awaken the
byakugan in his left eye this character
stood out to me in the hitachi light
novels the dude was so talented and
strong that donso compared him to
hitachi himself mukai was even confident
that he could defeat hitachi and shisui
uchiha but he did not know about the
mangekyo shoting on and ended up losing
interestingly enough he could apply the
principles of the gentle fist style and
focus it on an opponent's jutsu this
ability allowed him to cut a great
fireball in two leaving him unharmed i
personally thought that this detail was
especially hype when i first read it but
yeah that is it for all 14 members of
the clan and what we know about their
powers plus a bonus obviously there are
more clan members in the village but
these are the ones we know enough about
to actually discuss in a video and even
for some of these we didn't get much
information if you did enjoy this video
and want to keep the naruto videos like
this one coming chill the hokage within
and smash that like button with no mercy
and let me know what video topic you
would like to see covered next in the
comments if you haven't make this the
video you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
naruto videos and while you wait for the
next video to come out feel free to
check out my huge and growing naruto
playlist that includes videos on all the
kage uzumaki otozuki and much more link
to that is in the description as always
leave suggestions for topics or clans
you would love to see covered in the
comments and i especially want to thank
the patron squad over on patreon and
here on youtube who helped make videos
like this one possible first and
foremost i want to thank the patron of
legend the one acknowledged by lord wigo
himself alpha sigma and our one tier
patrons the ones who stand on top all
clans ingrata pate hepa al-jatal
hinokami and water the toasted tree the
spike corey mcgowan dylan isadore spidey
life tennelle tungsten tarkis baked
buddhist cody hebert monkey d quilly and
jeremy cummings and our pro hero to your
patrons the one and only gilgamesh the
red haired raven angel crews rethu and
deiora very gucci alicia actor bonnie
parks joanne garcia ted no ted and fat
boy games thank you all so much if you
do enjoy our work you can support more
of it by going over to patreon.com anime
uproar and becoming a patron today for
as little as one dollar if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos alongside these amazing people
right here and you'll even get access to
our private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
anime uproar link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel by clicking that blue
join button next to the subscribe button
that i hope you already smashed so yeah
you can support more content that way if
you prefer whichever way to support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you